hi guys i've recently been ill so i've
decided to play the long
dark i've heard quite a few things about
this game
it's basically like a sandbox at the
moment because it's still an
alpha apparently you can get eaten by
wolves so let's see if i can
stay out the world's way it's just
basically like a survival game
soon so let's get to do this
yeah let's just do this but mystery lake
or coastal highway i'll go coastal
highway because
it's winter so it it makes sense to go
in the snowy bit a mysterious guru
magazine storm has brought your planes
crashing down
into the north canadian wilderness how
long can you survive canadian
we might see laura here if you don't
know who she is do you need to
look at my um old videos
quite old now actually no list of things
to be done the day put
pro evidential to itself
the hour there is no later this is later
all things of grace and beauty such that
one holds
them to one's heart have a common
problem some pain their breath is grease
from the ashes
i read it oh i don't like that you can't
jump
though am i the only one that does that
you know when you start playing a game
you just
instinctively press the space and hope
to be jumping
i'm probably not i bet loads of people
do that oh look there's a lake in this
one as well
can we swim can we ice skate
please tell me we can ice skate we can
ice cake
well we can crack off the ice a bit
i wonder if i can die like this i
wouldn't really want to that'd be a
pretty
sucky um play through wouldn't it
oh look there's a little house over here
a little cabin there's a house there
i don't i really don't know if i can die
this way i wonder if there's anything
under the bridge
like a troll maybe i could be the troll
look at that buddy no bunny come back i
want to be your friend
buddy menu oh oh i have a match
i pressed m for menu when i got a match
oh oh
i have equipment i have antibiotics
bandage basic boots
bedroll i've got cotton long underwear
always essential for the winter weather
right so let's go to those um
oh those little houses that i saw
we'll find some good equipment there i
wish i had a little radio with me or an
ipod
everything's better with an ipod i want
to go to that one in the middle of the
in the middle of the icy lake
because the deer's walking on it if a
deer can walk on it
i can walk on it deer are
heavier than we are right come on i wish
you just skipped
that would be a hell of a lot cooler why
is there
a little shed on top of ice
anyway who would do that
and how long has this ice been here for
someone to actually build a shed or put
a shed on it
and this is nice it's a ice fishing hole
it's frozen i need i need things ah i
suck
okay is there things in here
nope what about this one best be
prepared for anything
beef jerky yeah
soda yeah this is how i envision
canada although i don't really think
about wolves i think more about bears
but i don't i haven't heard of bears
being in this game
i wouldn't be surprised or is it gonna
get nighttime
it's like minecraft but more realistic
is that one of those wolves
no i thought he might be like
nice nice wolfie okay
i'm going away i'm just not gonna look
behind me
oh i just wanted a pet wolf
to live with me in my house fine i'll go
in this little shed thing
they're everywhere it's like they just
fell out of the sky
none of them have doors either yeah
whatever
stop questioning things right what have
we got what we got
i'll take it yes i think you should oh
my god
oh my god i can hear him in my ears
i'm sorry what did i do again
am i doing it right what do i do
oh where did the game go
right this time let's take it up a notch
because i did so well last time oh look
it's a car car on the bridge
let's go to the car yeah i was gonna say
let's go into the woods
instead of staying on the non-icy
weird water let's see if the this car oh
enter the vehicle just sit in the car
for a while
oh let's read the paper let's see what's
going on
okay can i drive it radio
i was just saying about the radio oh
it's locked
i don't like all these noises
makes me feel uneasy oh the thing is
though they trick you because the wolves
actually look like
really cute but they're not
but i wish that they were i just want to
go in that house because
i want to explore it i think the coast
is clear
awesome all right let's go into these
houses
there's so many we're gonna get so much
loot
oh this is kind of creepy this is really
creepy
is there no one else here am i sure i'm
not just stealing someone else's
hard search for stuff what is this
locker i can hardly see anything
oh gosh it's so creepy in here right
let's get out
nothing here
the outdoors let's do this
to the outdoors ah it's a fishing camp
how very sweet let's see if we can find
anything of use
oh my god he's sorry he's gonna decide
to
get inside ah
i have to sleep until he goes away
oh it's a double bed this time is even
better
set all of the drawers
hopefully it's not just like waiting for
me outside
no the coast is clear where am i going
now
that is not a way oh look there's
something behind the house
enter another i am just a dirty thief
that's all i am she must have a massive
bag
i don't ever see it i just hear it it
must be huge
i wonder if you do ever bump into anyone
in the story because it is gonna have a
story
[ __ ]
how are you supposed to do good at this
game i don't know
let's just go to sleep oh
wait i'm waking at nighttime why am i
doing that
oh maybe they won't see me in the dark
but i don't even have a flashlight this
is a stupid idea
but it's a gun it's snowing
spot follow the path follow the path
we're following the path
that was terrible song
[ __ ] oh that's okay
like i'm thinking everything is a wolf
now is that
that's not a wolf is it no it's a rock
oh there was another little house up
here i think
on this mountain i want to go to the
mountains let's go to the mountain
okay i'm on a voyage to reach
the lonely mountain it
is here and that is my mission
oh god what is this this is a sandstorm
this is a snowstorm i mean there is no
stat stance
sand god sorry they gotta speak properly
oh my gosh i'm gonna be freezing cold
with all this let's
let's eat this
sardines hmm if only i could find
a nice hot flask of coffee
why did i go to sleep and wake up at
night time i'm so stupid
let's go come on you can make it
oh look look look house this house looks
awesome let's go in this door
i really don't like how dark it is
nowhere has
oh can i turn this on can we turn this
on
nope of course not let's open this
tv doesn't work typical
fridge who loves orange soda
kale loves art sodas
probably useful i've caused so many
matches what do i use them for though
maybe to light up this place oh my god
i'm so stupid why didn't i think of that
before oh
i can put some stuff in here be like my
little home
but no i don't want to
i wish they did it really would make the
game i i guess it wouldn't be as
realistic but it would make the game a
bit more
ah this will come in handy oh yes it
will
can i can i wear that now was it cold
again
fleece yeah
much better this place is so eerie
what happened to everyone oh what's this
you really want to take toilet water i
guess
i guess she doesn't have any choice okay
right let's get some sleep
yeah so she will wake up
at
6 19. okay let's go explore some more
this is really fun i mean it's like so
simple but
oh look it's the morning oh it looks
really nice
yeah just it's a really simple concept i
think when it's got a story in it as
well
i'm going to love it i just wish she
could jump
and run running would be good
apparently i can toggle to one oh my god
she's running okay i take back
everything that i just said she hasn't
run in look at her go
oh this makes the game so much better
out on the wall again
and here comes a wolf
and there's another wolf and we're just
gonna stroll past
the wolves oh no she can't run up
hills come on you can do this
if you could jump this would be a lot
easier oh my gosh
oh i thought i was saying that she had
something wrong with her but no it's
someone's homestead and i get nice music
oh my god everything that i'm
complaining about it just gives me
you were just teasing me
oh okay
like this music will definitely be
better once it's got a story you can
just tell it's all lined up for a good
story
so this is their family
how much can i she holds i mean i'm not
complaining
but she can hold a lot of stuff surely
whatever's in the fridge and freezer
can't actually be cold anymore because
the
all the electricity's left twizzled here
is gone right this will come in handy
dog food oh so i can give that to the
wolves and they'll stop chasing me
and they can be my pet maybe
probably not i can always try
and we're off right let's see if i can
outsmart these worlds
just you know before i stop playing i
just want to say
i am smarter than a wolf
okay here's a wolf okay here we go
venison cook drop and run
it's the cooked venison it's so yummy
yes yes yes it worked
i'm so pleased with myself i didn't
think i was gonna wet
yay bye bye wolf no don't say he comes
after me
still are you kidding me
no i just gave him some food
i just gave you some food you should be
thanking me if anything
fine i'm just going to back up
there you go have a matchstick for your
freezing hands
oh my gosh
wait was it actually breaking there i
don't know
oh my gosh she is
i drowned i didn't think you could drown
ah it was all those things that i was
eating i was obviously just getting
fatter
i survived for 19 hours though nearly
20. now
that's not too bad for my first one i
think that was pretty good
i think that was a really cool game i
personally really enjoyed it i know it's
not
all action-packed and but i quite like
just being able to explore and do your
own thing
i wish there was more wilderness kind of
areas maybe there is maybe i just
didn't follow the right places to go to
them but
i think it's pretty cool let me know
what you thought of this game and give
it a thumbs up if you enjoyed watching
have a lovely day or evening
bye can i close my eyes and then it's
not real
a psychological psychological it's like
no i'm already freaking out i don't like
this